last night four Republicans who won't be
the Presidential nominee in 2024 faced
off in Tuscaloosa Florida Governor Ron
Des sanus opened the debate by going
after Nikki Haley who fired back at
DeSantis and attacked V ramaswami who
brutally attacked Nikki Haley who was
defended by Chris Christie who most
people forgot was even there and I am
Michael nolles and this is the Michael
nolles
Show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode's
brought to you by jell skincare go to
Jus cell.com kwes to get an incredible
holiday discount on their most popular
package also lady Ballers is now the
most popular screaming movie on on
Rotten Tomatoes our first fulllength
feature comedy is the biggest launch in
Daily wire history it is now the number
one streaming movie anywhere are you not
a member well lucky for you with Coach
the code coach you can become a part of
daily War plus and save 50 bucks on new
annual
memberships speaking of things to stream
I watched that whole debate last night
even though it is just completely
pointless and will not have any
practical effect I thought it might
somewhat entertaining and I suppose it
could tell us assuming they don't
assassinate Donald Trump it could tell
us who Trump could pick for VP it could
tell us who Trump might pick for a
cabinet position if he were to be
elected so it was worth watching I'm
irritated at the debate for a second
reason second reason being as those of
you watching right now can see I am not
in my studio I'm on the road I was at
Clemson last night but for whatever
reason they scheduled my speech at
Clemson at exactly the same time as the
Republican presidential debate so those
jerks in Tuscaloosa took views away from
my speech but you can catch that speech
on the yaf YouTube channel that is a
speech called kids are not Commodities
on IVF and surrogacy which is a
controversial issue not just for the
libs but even among conservatives so you
can go check that out there meanwhile I
come back I get back to my hotel very
late at night and I watch this whole
debate what stood out to me right from
the outset was
that Ronda santis has had enough of
Nikki Haley Nikki Haley has been taking
Ronda sanz's perspective donors
prospective support base prospective
campaign Network in the early primary
States and he's had enough of it so he
opens up the debate going after Nikki I
am sick of Republicans who are not
willing to stand up and fight back
against what the left is doing to this
country you've got to be willing to
stand strong and you've got to be
willing to beat these people I'm the
only one running for president that has
beaten these people on issue after issue
uh we beat the teachers unions when we
did school choice we beat fouchy on Co
we beat George Soros and you have other
candidates up here like Nikki Haley she
caves anytime the left comes after her
anytime the media comes after her I did
a bill in Florida to stop the gender
mutilation of minors it's child abuse
and it's wrong she opposes that bill she
thinks it's fine and the law shouldn't
get involved with it you're not willing
to stand up for the kids if you're not
willing to stand up and say that it is
wrong to mutilate these kids uh then
you're not going to fight for the people
back home I will fight for you and I
will win for you I thought this was a
very strong answer in terms of the words
that Governor DeSantis was using I
thought this was a really strong point
on the actual issue which is Nikki got
in trouble a couple of days ago for
saying she doesn't think the law has a
place in telling parents not to that is
a view held by a significant minority of
Republicans especially in blue states on
the coasts in the more I don't know the
the Wall Street set of Republicans but
it's it's certainly not a view held by
the Bas the Bas believes that we need to
stop it's just wrong and we got to cut
it out so DeSantis I think articulated
that view and I I do think that that
happens to be the correct view one one
thing that struck me by his answer and I
think this might be in part why Governor
Dan santis is having trouble connecting
is his
answer in the in the content of it it's
very strong I did this I wielded power I
have a clear moral Vision I'm the man I
got it done I won all of which is true
the tone of the answer is a little bit
whiny the tone of the answer is and come
on and I did this and you know we did
come on the only guy and you d d d and I
know that shouldn't matter a lot of
people believe we should just vote on
people's records and these little things
like the even the tone of one's voice uh
seems so trivial it's a presidential
debate and I I do wonder if that in part
is the reason why he had trouble
connecting the nearest I've seen to this
sort of problem in a presidential debate
actually goes back over 10 years ago
goes back to John Huntsman another guy
actually I really like he had the same
problem his voice was kind of a a little
bit it had tone that was almost like he
was complaining and it was a little it
was a lamentation instead of you think
of a candidate like Trump who did very
well at the debates even though
sometimes the semantics of his answers
didn't were incoherent but he he did
really really well one because he's
funny he's quick on his feet but two
there was an ease to his rhetoric yeah
look I'm here you're going to be locked
up if I if I get elected no one even
believed that but but it just sounded
cool he sounded in command uh
so I think this might help to explain
why D santis could have all the right
answers he could do all the right things
in Florida but he's he's still failing
to connect Nick Nikki Haley actually had
quite a bit more Ease on the debate
stage last night uh so you had two teams
you had DeSantis and vake versus Nikki
and Christie which makes sense because
you that means you have the more
right-wing populist side of the GOP
versus the more Centrist establishment
side of the G GOP
so
Christie though he seems to hate V
ramaswami the most on that stage he took
his first attack to go after Ronda
santis and it was very clear from the
outset he was trying to relive the 2016
debates when he destroyed Marco Rubio we
stand with Israel they're our best ally
in the Middle East we have a unique
relationship with them uh and you will
see a strong relationship when I'm the
president of the United States Elizabeth
Elizabeth Elizabeth
th this is the problem with the first
three debates Ron gets asked a question
and he doesn't answer it your question
was very specific you said would you
send American troops as
commanderin-chief
and he went on to this minute 30 second
hosana about his knowledge of the
military and what we need to do and
didn't answer your question look when
your president of the United States
you're not going to have a choice
whether to answer that question or not
your generals your secretary defense
your secretary of state your National
Security adviser are going to present
plans to you they're going to look at
you and say do we go or don't we Mr
President and you can't give a 90c
speech about your military services what
would you send American troops into
absolutely
absolutely so I don't think it worked it
worked in 2016 you can't relive your
past glories when he said here's the can
30 second speech from Rubio and then
Rubio just unbelievably unbelievably
just launched into the exact same
30second speech again I don't think
Barack Obama doesn't know what he's
doing I think he knows exactly what he's
doing hey look at Rubio he sounds like a
robot what are you talking I'm not a
robot Barack Obama knows exactly what
he's doing beep beep beep boop and
Christy totally killed it this didn't
work here he was going after Dan santis
in the same way he went after Rubio by
saying this guy is stiff and he's he's
attempting to be a slick politician and
he's attempting to evade the answers and
just use his focus group remarks I don't
think it quite worked what that answer
tells me though is Christie knows he's
not going to be president he probably
always knew he was not going to be
president but politicians can delude
themselves so 50/50 he now knows he's
not going to be president this is the
last debate before the Iowa caucuses
this dude somehow made it throughout the
whole process before the primary and
caucus is kicked off but he's got to
pick a team now we're now down to four
people and Chris Christie is on team
Nikki Haley in fact he's so clearly on
team Nikki Haley that after V ramaswami
attacked n attacked Nikki for saying uh
that she I don't know she was giving
some remark about the military and V
said you're bought and paid for by the
military industrial complex you're
corrupt you took money from Boeing this
was a theme that recurred throughout the
night which we'll get to in just a
second Chris Christie comes out and
white nights for Nikki Haley we're now
25 minutes into this debate and he has
insulted Nikki Haley's basic
intelligence not her positions her basic
intelligence she doesn't know regions
she wouldn't be able to find something
on a map that his three-year-old could
find look if you want to disagree on
issues that's fine and Nikki and I
disagree on some issues but I'll tell
you this I've known her for 12 years
which is longer than he's even started a
vote in a Republican
primary and while we disagree about some
issues and we disagree about who should
be president of the United States what
we don't disagree on is this is a smart
accomplished woman you should stop
insulting so I'm going to take
this there's the white nighting and
there's Nikki actually played it off
pretty well oh thank you Chris that's so
go on please uh but he he's picked his
side so those were the two sides of the
debate why was
Christy going after V because moments
prior the brutally attacked Nikki Haley
which we'll get to in a second but if
you're brutally attacked you probably
need some healthcare you you want to
check out Medishare right now go to
medishare.com m i h AEL as a dailywire
listener you're not just informed you're
engaged and sexy you value freedom and
personal responsibility that's why you
got to check out Medishare Medishare is
a community-based approach to healthcare
that lines up with the principles you
believe in your values matter and with
Medishare your Healthcare dollars will
not be used for medical procedures that
don't line up with your beliefs
Medishare is the highest rated
Healthcare sharing Ministry with a
30-year proven track record it's not
health insurance it's a community of
400,000 Believers committed to caring
and sharing with one another members
save up to 50% or more on their monthly
healthare costs and member satisfaction
surveys show they like Meda share much
more than health insurance why because
it works for a limited time dailywire
listeners will receive a $150 gift card
when they join Medishare to find out
more go to medishare.com that is
medishare.com
AEL terms and conditions apply the
like Ronda sandz has had enough of Nikki
Haley so the
brutally attacks her now a lot of the
neocons are quietly coming along to that
position with the exceptions of Nikki
Haley and Joe Biden who still support
this what I believe is pointless war in
Ukraine and I think those with foreign
policy experience one thing that Joe
Biden and Nikki Haley have in common is
that neither of them could even state
for you three provinces in eastern
Ukraine that they want to send our
troops to actually fight for look at
that this is what I want people to
understand these people have I mean she
has no idea what the hell the names of
those provinces are but she wants to
send our sons and daughters and our
troops and our military equipment to go
fight it so reject this myth that
they've been selling you that somebody
had a cup of coffee stint at the UN and
then makes 8 million bucks after has
real foreign policy experience it takes
an outsider to see this through look at
the blank expression she doesn't know
the names of the provinces that she
wants to actually fight for and there's
a pump right there
this was
brutal I saw people on both sides of V
uh reacting to this in Extreme Ways
now I think the Divide here is an age
divide I think Zoomers love V I think
Gen X Boomers don't really like V and
they find him to be a little precocious
and they find him to be a little over
the top
uh you're also seeing some divide on on
just the two parts of the party the more
restrained part of the GOP foreign
policy uh base really likes V really
doesn't like Nikki Haley the more
interventionist imperialist side of the
GOP obviously hates V you know he does
pretty well among the Buchanan Trump
kind of set he he obviously does not do
well among the neoconservatives that's
why he he attacks the neoconservatives
but worth pointing out I think Mike
cernovich made this point too this was a
very very risky move for V
because if if he had launched this
attack and then Nikki had just leaned
into the microphone and named three
regions of Ukraine he would have looked
terrible he would have looked like a
total fool but he took the bet that she
couldn't name the regions and she
couldn't and I don't know you probably
can't name the regions either I don't
what are regions in eastern Ukraine
detet Moscow and Beijing is that it I
don't know those I know there's are
vaguely East is that no one really knows
V does because V is a super genius and
you know I I was an undergraduate when V
was at the law school the guy has had a
reputation as a sharp fella for a very
very long time so he Nails her on this
tensions arising it was the most tense
GOP debate by far the moment the only
moment that anyone is going to remember
is going to be between the
and Nikki and it was another polarizing
moment people think it was the stupidest
moment of the debate people think it was
the greatest moment of the debate it is
where V held up a pad of paper with all
of his notes from the debate and his his
notes just had two words two words and
one sign she said that I have a woman
problem Nikki I don't have a woman
problem you have a corruption problem
and I think that that's what people need
to know Nikki is corrupt this is a woman
who will send your kids to die so she
can buy a bigger house this is the
problem using identity politics more
effectively than Kamala Harris is a form
of intellectual fraud and it actually
needs and there's our donor Puppet
Masters wielding their puppet right up
here tonight this is how this game is
played the Puppet Masters put up their
puppet and I reject the use of identity
politics in this party it has been a
cancer coming from the left and I'm sick
and tired of the double standards the
people of this country are too having
two chromosomes does not immunize you
from thank you
sir so some people the more clubbable
let's all get a long type of Republicans
are going to look at this and say oh
vake come on this is a ridiculous stunt
you're doing prop comedy on that stage
now come on out this is so beneath the
tenor of a presidential debate first of
all there is nothing beneath the tenor
of these presidential debates these are
the stupidest shows that have that have
ever been put on in the history of the
United States including every reality
show of the mid
2000s all of it these are pointless
stupid nasty shallow debates for the
most part so I don't think that attack
really works and even if you don't like
that kind of a stunt ask
yourself did it work of course it worked
it's the only thing that anyone is
talking about the V whom no one had
heard of until he ran for president very
few people he had written some books he
was he was somewhat known but very few
people had heard of him is now a
national political figure he has
cemented himself firmly on the
conservative
populist guess prot Trump side of the
GOP Trump is almost certainly going to
be the nominee this guy I don't know
this guy could be Secretary of State or
something he's just done an excellent
excellent job in this race does the
attack stick I'm not sure that people
are now going to view Nikki Haley as a
Joe Biden or a Hillary Clinton just
pedaling influence around the world the
attack was that after she left the UN
position she took some board positions
and gave some corporate speeches and she
made a good amount of money doing it
that's true a lot of politicians do that
I'm not sure that it's it's the most
precise attack but as we is especially
we've learned from Donald Trump these
little one-word two-word lines kind of
stick and the reason this has a chance
of sticking is because Nikki is at a low
Point among conservatives at other times
conservatives have liked her when when
Nikki was at the UN and she was beating
all the worst people in the world
conservatives loved her she's also had
more moderate and Centrist positions and
actions in her political career where
the conservatives don't like that and
right now days after she said and she's
now trying to walk it back but days
after she said that if a child wants to
transition you should let the parents do
it the law has no role in that the knew
that Nikki is at a very very low Point
among conservatives so he's going to
pounce and try to destroy her political
career we will see if that works
uh all of this to say not one debate has
ever moved the needle on the polls in
any meaningful way not one campaign ad
not one speech not one rally not one
indictment not one nothing has has moved
the
needle in as much as the needle has
moved Trump has gained a little bit of
support Dan santis has lost a little bit
of support the vake went from no name
recognition to some support and Nikki
has fluctuated a little bit and somehow
christe is still in the race but it it
just doesn't matter so the the Democrats
have resigned themselves to the fact
that Trump is the nominee maybe they
wanted him to be the nominee maybe they
think Trump is easy to beat though I'm
not sure I'm not sure that the Democrats
really believe that that's the line
you're hearing out of the disantis
campaign and the Haley campaign I'm not
sure that that's true because fool me
once shame on you fool me twice he the
point is you're not going to fool me
again to quote George W bush that was
their tactic in 2016 the Democrats said
let let's get Trump to be the nominee
Bill Clinton called Donald Trump and
said you should run for president this
was this was part of the Democrat
strategy the Republicans should nominate
the craziest wackiest guy in the whole
party and then Hillary's going to just
wal thre into the White House and it
didn't work so I think they're probably
going to be a little more cautious this
time and and so the Democrats have a new
attack on Trump the new attack is that
Donald Trump okay he's going to be the
nominee he's probably going to he he's
probably going to be the Nomine he might
get elected and if he is elected he is
going to be an absolute terrible awful
dictator
now if you are a parent if you're a
frequent traveler if you're an
individual seeking enhanced personal
security you're going to want to check
out Pac Shield right now go to Pac
shield.com use promo code nolles whether
you are apparent a frequent traveler
simply an individual seeking enhanced
personal safety you got to check out Pac
Shield Pac Shield is a ballistic insert
that fits into backpacks messenger bags
and briefcases the inserts meet the
National Institute of justice and 3A
standards to stop up to a 44 magnum pack
Shield comes in a variety of sizes and
colors so they can be easily transferred
from bag to bag and way less than most
textbooks and laptops when properly
packed in your bag this remarkable
insert can provide an extra layer of
protection I have a couple of pack
Shields the nice thing about them is
that no one can tell me that I have got
this in my luggage briefcase or bag they
just have no idea they are extremely
lightweight and I love knowing that I am
protected it's stressful to think about
a situation where you might need pack
Shield it is worth it to be ready pack
Shield provides extra peace of mind it's
important to know how to carry it
correctly pack Shield should never be
used for any reason other than personal
defense so packs and protection and
peace of mind with Pac Shield check them
out for yourself at Pac shield.com promo
code NS kwas for 2020% off that is Pak
shield.com promo code noes canw for 20%
off today when the daily wire made lady
balers we made history with our first
ever full length comedy then we made
history again this week when lady balers
skyrocketed to become the nation's
number one streaming movie all thanks to
your incredible support with a solid 94%
audience SC on Rotten Tomatoes thousands
of user reviews lady Ballers is the
return of the comedies that we love if
you've not watched lady Ballers it's
time to join in on the laughs if you
have friends family co-workers pets who
have not yet watched lady Ballers get
each of them a separate daily wirus
subscription tell them quote they have
to watch the number one movie in
America I'm sure many people are saying
that streaming exclusively on dailywire
plus take a quick look at the nation's
top streamed movie from the daily wire
lady
ballers in a world where women's
sports is being
transformed the daily wire calls foul
with the most triggering comedy of the
year
guys this is serious sports can be your
pathway to a better life well like yours
please don't steal my catalytic
converter again winning matters it's the
key ingredient in becoming a winner
maybe you should try it
sometime are you going to move I am
not let's cut to the chase I know you're
not a woman hey you don't know how he
identified if you can beat them what do
you know about the US opens for the
global games you want us to compete as
women $5,000 prizes my lover says you're
a great coach back in the day doing this
is the way the world is now my
8-year-old daughter told me all about it
so a guy can become a girl with no
physical changes at all oh that's called
gender fluid so I can be a woman on the
court and a man in the bedroom I can't
believe it nice you mean when you're
sleeping yes Coach Alex we could play
basketball we have to get the whole team
back together it's time we're in I'm in
I'm in to play Lady balers M
up like a girl gu what I'm with
her is my TR this is my
trth from Heroes day one of being a girl
athlete I love being a girl do sheo we
could dominate every woman's sport
running swimming soccer I said sport
Felix it's ladies basketball Boys Nobody
watches excuse me are these seats
open never mind getting
dunks and tuing
Trunks
you know she
[Music]
didn't that's the biggest I've ever seen
on a lady I don't care lady
Ballers one can even be trans aged now
which provides shelix with a wonderful
opportunity to relive all the
experiences that she missed out on in
school streaming exclusively on daily
wire plus December
1st
[Music]
our goal is clear lady Ballers stays at
the top outdoing last weekend's
Blockbuster opening as the number one
movie in America if you don't have daily
we plusus membership it's time to join
yes monthly memberships are just $14.99
you can cancel any time it's your chance
to join the daily wire and witness
history by watching lady Ballers get
your dailywire Plus Membership now at
dailywire.com
ssubscribe
now turning back to the only show in
America that can rival the lady balers
movie in terms of entertainment and
craziness that would of course be the
presidential race Trump's
opponents the really squish Republicans
in the libs have a new line of attack
and that is that Donald Trump is going
to be a dictator uh Robert Kagan who's a
a foreign policy fixture in Washington
uh he said on Friday uh and he this is a
Washington Post editor at large he he
said a trump dictatorship is
increasingly
inevitable we should stop
pretending and not increasingly likely
increasingly
inevitable I always liked the kagens
Robert kagan's father was a professor of
mine a an amazing incredible Professor
an incredible historian I expect more of
the Kagan family than this kind of
hysterical nonsense but he's not the
only one this was clearly coordinated
isan Thor the fear of a looming Trump
dictatorship this was in the post the
Atlantic announced on Monday that it's
going to have a special issue that warns
of the grave and extreme consequences if
Trump were to win in 2024 argues that
Trump and Trump is imposing existential
threat to America and the ideas that
animate
it couple conclusions from this one the
libs believe that Trump is going to be
the nominee they were going after
disantis for a little while that's over
they have not really gone after Haley
yet they'll see I guess if she can if
she can show movement on her poll
numbers they haven't gone after Chris
Christie they haven't they're going
after Trump they think that Trump is the
nominee Biden is already treating Trump
as the nominee Trump is already treating
Trump as the nominee now the Washington
establishment is doing that too the
other scarier conclusion I draw from
this
is the purpose of this kind of
language is to justify violence against
Trump that's what this is
about there is no evidence that Trump is
going to be a dictator we know that we
know that there's no evidence of this
because Trump was already elected one
time he wasn't a dictator I in fact I
wish he had wielded power more
effectively he did he did a good job I'm
not really knocking him too much but I
wish he had done even more we know he's
not a dictator we know that he won't
stay in office forever because he left
office voluntarily even after they
rigged the election on him and there was
a lot of evidence that they rigged the
election we all saw with our eyes he
still left office so's the only reason
to say this guy he's a dictator he poses
an existential that is to say life or
death threat to our country is to
justify violence against them the
Liberals justify violence against a
whole lot of people they've done it for
many many years they say that our speech
is violence that's why they encourage
their their militant Wing to go attack
us on campuses I got a I got a very nice
welcome here at Clemson last night when
I went to Pittsburgh in the spring
antifa militants tried to blow me
up and why did the antifa militants try
to blow me up because for years we've
had mainstream Democrats say you can't
be civil with Republicans you got to
push back on them in public spaces you
got to go to their homes where the
children sleep and scream and intimidate
them and then what do you get then you
get the attacks that's what this is
about and it's the last thing they have
left to do they robbed Trump by RI
rigging the election they robbed Trump
of his administration in in some ways by
uh constantly trying to undercut it with
all these bogus investigations that were
cooked up based on nothing where the FBI
colluded with the Democrats and with the
Hillary Clinton campaign to use fake
evidence to spy on Trump's campaign to
stop him from getting elected in the
first place he gets elected to undermine
his administration and the ability to
actually get things done and then they
change all the election laws and rig the
election so they can boot him out then
he's still coming back he's still
popular so they're going to indict him a
bunch of times at the local level at the
federal level they're going to try to to
put him in in prison for 700 years and
if that doesn't work there's nothing
left to do what are you going to the
only thing you going to do is say that
guy is going to be a Tiant he's going to
seize power he's going to kill the
country existential threat and and so
what does that imply it implies that the
Leb should kill him first that's what
they're after so is Trump going to be a
dictator he was asked this question by
Shan Hannity here's the response to be
clear do you in any way have any plans
whatsoever if reelected president
to abuse power to break the law to use
the government to go after people you
mean like they're using right now under
no circumstances you are promising
America tonight you would never abuse
power as retribution against anybody
except for day one except for he's going
crazy except for day one meaning I want
to close the border and I want to drill
drill that's not that's not
retribution I got I'm going to be
I'm going to be you know he keeps we
love this guy he says you're not going
to be a dictator are you I said no no no
other than day one we're closing the
border and we're drilling drilling
drilling after that I'm not a dictator
okay I I love all that stuff and it's a
very funny answer he first he says Oh
you mean like they're doing you mean am
I going to do all the stuff that they're
doing right now but what he comes to the
final point that he comes to is he says
I'm not going to be a dictator other
than on day one day one I'm want to be a
dictator
meaning Sean Hannity is shocked he's
saying no please don't stop saying this
Donald he goes no no no day one I'm
going to be a dictator I'm gonna build
the border wall I'm gonna fire a bunch
of people I'm going to do this I'm going
to do that and Hannity says oh okay so
you're not going to be a dictator right
yeah no other than on day one this
answer is the 2024 version of uh I don't
want to live in a country that Donald
Trump is president in and he says yeah
cuz should' be in jail it's that quick
witted response that people aren't
taking totally seriously but they're not
not taking
seriously I think this is a perfect
answer here and it gets to something
that's totally missing at the GOP
debates right now where everyone's just
so tense Trump has that ease goes oh
yeah yeah am I going to am I going to go
after my political enemies by wielding
government you mean like they've been
doing for my entire public life uh nah
no I don't think so although you know
one of my favorite figures is Al Capone
he's just joke he's just toying with
everyone here including with Shan
Hannity and it's it's very effective
It's very
effective you saw this especially after
I think it was the fourth indictment
Trump comes out and he gives a press
conference and he's cool as a cucumber
do not
underestimate the importance of that
quality at a time where everything seems
so uncertain people are so tense
everyone at each other's throats ease is
a very very attractive quality and I'm
not saying that's the reason why he's 50
points up in the GOP race probably that
is just a structural matter of him
running effectively as an incumbent this
time and his reshaping of the Republican
party and the fact that he's been a big
celebrity for 40 years
but that ease that that that puts at
least his supporters at ease that's kind
of funny that's entertaining that's not
so tense that's not the same old script
that we've seen before that that can be
very very attractive right now the
liberal establishment just looks very
very small here's a story this broke two
days ago no one's even talking about it
I didn't even get to it on the show
yesterday
because it's just it's just more of the
same it's just more of what we've heard
but in any other Administration in any
other time this would be absolutely
shocking front page international news
Joe Biden has been caught receiving
monthly payments from Hunter Biden's sh
shell corporations the shell
corporations that were used to Pedal
American influence overseas shake down
some of the worst people in the world
remember Joe Biden said oh you think my
son who's who's scooping up millions and
millions of dollars from from influence
pedlers all around the world you think
that's evidence of my corruption show me
the money show where's the money man
come on Jack listen here Corn Pop where
that money underneath my hairy legs yeah
that's where it is we found the money
James comr house oversight committee has
discovered direct monthly payments from
Hunter Biden's AA PC business account
which received payments from Chinese
State linked companies and other foreign
Nationals and companies going to Joe
Biden's personal accounts as comr says
this was not a payment from Hunter
Biden's personal account which that
would be weird too usually children
don't give their parents money certainly
not when their parents are um US
senators and vice presidents and
presidents National politicians for 5050
years usually maybe if you're parents
fell on Hard Times you'd give them some
money even if it were a personal account
that would be weird enough this is
actually from Hunter's business account
that received money directly from all
these Shady Chinese State linked
entities says Joe Biden claimed there
was an absolute wall between his
official government duties and his fam's
influence pedaling schemes this was a
lie they've got this guy dead to rights
and much like the go presidential
debate doesn't really matter it doesn't
it doesn't matter
because there's no new information
here there's there is new evidence
there's firmer more obvious
evidence of something that we all know
is already happening if the original
Hunter Biden
scandal did not jar you did not get you
to turn on Biden for his corruption then
nothing will when the the hunter bid
Scandal broke years ago at this point we
knew that Hunter was being paid in
insane sums of money by Ukrainian oil
companies he doesn't know anything about
Ukraine or oil we knew that he was
raising a ton of money out of China we
knew he was and we know Hunter is a
complete degenerate who it doesn't have
any any practical hard skills in in any
profession so any money he's getting is
obviously just because of his last name
and we know that Joe Biden's brother
does the same thing we know that Joe
Biden's other brother does the same
thing we know that Joe Biden said he
never talked to Hunter about his
business we then heard Hunter admit that
he talked to Joe Biden about his
business and then we saw on Hunter
Biden's laptop that he actually not only
talked to Joe about the business but
talked about how he gave Joe a bunch of
money if you were not persuaded by that
then you're going to support Joe and why
are Democrats supporting Joe right now
because they think he's an upstanding
public-minded guy no they're doing it
because he's the representative of their
team and they think that the other guy's
corrupt I don't think Trump is really
corrupt by the standards of a guy who
worked in New York real estate in the
80s I think he is clean as a whistle uh
compared to Biden and the clintons I
think he's clean as a whistle but the
Liberals think that that Trump is
corrupt and so now you've got a battle
between two sides both of which
are are speaking quite openly about
corruption this is what marks the decay
of of a regime it's it's not so much
ideological we focus on the ideological
part and that matters too the fact that
our uh governing Ideology Now is deeply
anti-American anti-christian anti-truth
it denies basic biological realities you
know we talk about the critical race
theory in the schools and the gender
ideology in the schools and this is the
the the real decay of the American
regime yeah that's a big part of it but
actually uh for all of history going
back to Great observers of these
phenomena like
pus uh the real marker of a regime
decaying is the turn away from public
interest to private interest this is the
difference between a monarchy and a
tyranny monarchy is concerned with the
common good tyranny is concerned with
enriching the ruler it's the difference
between an aristocracy and an oligarchy
it's the difference between even a
democracy a republic such as perhaps we
once had and MOB rule one governs
according to Virtue for the common good
one just seeks to enrich itself and
that's where we are we have open public
corruption
at the very highest levels of government
and the the clearest marker there for
the decay of the regime is that the
American people just shrug their
shoulders yeah more of the same doesn't
look good now when you want to look good
you got to check out genell right now go
to genucell.com
kwes I have got a Christmas gift idea
that is sure to make you the hero of the
Season we all know that the holidays can
be a little bit hectic the shopping the
cooking the never ending list of things
to do if you're not because we have
discovered the gift that is not just
thoughtful it's downright transformative
that is the gift of genus cell skincare
from now until Christmas genell's most
popular package has a special discount
just for our listeners at genucell.com
wle treat yourself and your loved ones
to the absolute greatest skincare in the
world those troubling forehead wrinkles
Fine Lines skin redness yes even a
sagging jawline will disappear right
before your eyes with genu cell's most
popular collection cell promises
immediate effects you will see results
in less than 12 hours guaranteed or your
money back Jus cell made Christmas come
early this year they sent down a ton of
products for the entire office everyone
is raving about their under eye bag
cream it works wonders you deserve to
look and feel your best this season you
know I love the founder of this company
Copic Christian from Egypt left for the
American dream their products use the
absolute best ingredients out there go
to jal.com get this incredible Christmas
discount every order today is instantly
upgraded graded to free express shipping
jus.com
today my favorite comment yesterday is
from Batman for president 9655 who says
calling ibram x kendi a real Professor
is like calling the professor from
Gilligan's Island a real Professor oh
it's even worse than that calling ibram
x kendi ibram x kendi is like calling
the actor from Gilligan's Island a real
Professor that's not his name his name
is Henry Rogers but Henry Rogers sounds
too white so he started to go by
ebram and and then when he got married
he and his wife who also had a totally
normal sing name they decided to just
make up a new name so the ibram X kendi
identity is a role it's a it's a role to
be played and it's very effective it's
made him a lot of money it's a very
lucrative part to play while you go out
there and do a little soft shoe for the
liberal Elite and and make millions and
millions of dollars doing it they gave
this guy who has Absolut absolutely no
business at a university they gave him
his his own Center his own Institute the
center for anti-racist research which is
finally being investigated because it
was completely bogus it you want to talk
about Al Capone it was nothing other
than a sin ofure for ibram kendi and a
little line for his resume so that he
could go on TV and with his fictional
name and his fictional credentials go on
and give a fictional account of of race
relations and
history unfortunately right now now
Republicans are too weak to pose a
serious threat to Joe Biden we have a
great Speaker of the House Mike Johnson
really like him Rock ribed conservative
guy we have I guess a majority on the
Supreme Court kind of Court's a little
different but I don't even know how long
we're going to have the Republican
speaker in the house because Kevin
McCarthy former speaker ousted
unceremoniously by mat Matt Gates uh has
decided he's going to leave Congress by
the end of the year fair enough enough I
mean if you're ousted by your own
conference in this brutal historic way
uh yeah you're you're probably going to
get out a Dodge you're not going to go
back to being a backbencher congressman
this guy's been in leadership for like
over 10 years so uh he's gone that means
that our five Republican majority is it
four or five Republican majority now now
it's
down then you got George
Santos being expelled from Congress and
a lot of Republicans voted for it look I
think Santos is probably guilty of all
the stuff they're accusing him of I
think it's very serious crimes that
Dante puts in the very pit of Hell I
don't think he should run for
re-election he said he wouldn't run for
re-election I probably would not have
voted to expel him over what the crimes
that the guy committed I think are
really really bad Democrats do the same
stuff in some ways in a more egregious
way they they knock George Santos for
lying about his ethnic background for
saying that he might he had a Jewish
Grandma which maybe he did no one really
knows meanwhile Elizabeth Warren becomes
a Harvard Harvard professor her by
pretending to be Native American and
then she finds out she's 1 10,000 150
billionth Cherokee or something and she
touts this is evidence that she actually
is Native
American all right get rid of get rid
of Warren get rid of Bob Menendez good
you want to talk about corruption Bob
Mendez is engaged in way more corruption
than George Santos at least at a much
higher scale so I wouldn't have voted to
expel him and the reason for that is now
you got a five vote majority okay you
lose you lose McCarthy you lose Santos
yikes we're at a three vote majority
uhoh Bill Johnson Republican Bill
Johnson is also leaving to become a
college President okay now we're down to
a two vote majority how much longer are
we going to have that by the way Patrick
McKenry the guy who was the acting
temporary speaker he's not running for
re-election next year Boop okay uh oh
yikes man we're really are Republicans
going to be able to hold on to any power
at all doesn't seem very clear to me now
speaking of Congress there was a scene
that took place in Congress this week
that even with my low opinion of I
League
administrators exceeded even my my
lowest
expectations this would be the scene in
which ivy league university presidents
hemmed and hawed over whether calling
for the genocide of the Jews explicitly
constitutes harassment at pen does
calling for the genocide of Jews violate
Penn's rules or code of conduct yes or
no if the speech turns into conduct it
can be harassment yes I am asking
specifically calling for the genocide of
Jews does that constitute bullying or
harassment if it is directed and severe
or pervasive it is harassment so the
answer is yes it is is a context
dependent decision congresswoman it's a
context dependent decision that's your
testimony today calling for the genocide
of Jews is depending upon the context
that is not bullying or harassment this
is the easiest question to answer yes
Miss
McGill so is your testimony that you
will not answer yes if it uh is if the
spech becomes if the speech becomes
conduct it can be harassment yes conduct
meaning committing the Act of genocide
does calling for the genocide of Jews
violate Harvard's rules of bullying and
harassment yes or no it can be depending
on the
context no you've got this is the line
it's not even just the the lady from
Penn it's multiple University presidents
you've got multiple representatives of
the ivy league here they say well you
know what's genocide one man's genocide
is another man's Freedom Fighter right
that's I guess that's sort of what
they're implying I'm all for nuance I
I'm truly all for nuance and I'm all for
protecting a wide um range of debate at
universities I'm I I do actually like
that but what we're seeing
here the the reason these University
presidents can't answer this is not
because they hate the Jews I don't maybe
they do hate the Jews but maybe they
don't I don't I don't think that's what
is motivating their answer what we're
seeing here is not just that they're TR
by their students which they are they
they're very afraid of upsetting the
students because the students run the
show now at the
universities what they're trapped by
primarily is their own free speech
rhetoric that's the thing and if it were
a different issue being discussed here
the Republicans would be on their
side because they're saying look we
don't you can say whatever you want at
the University and we support Free
Speech now we know that that's bogus
that's the the problem here if they
actually held to that rule I would give
them credit I'm not sure I would agree
with them I actually wrote a whole book
about how I disagree with free speech
absolutism called speechless controlling
words controlling Minds do I have a bell
on the road is there a bell
here no okay all right that's fine we'll
have to bring a bell on the road next
time uh
they they are saying that we don't
unless you actually commit the action of
genocide
uh that would not violate our policy and
then they kind of knew that was too
extreme so they're kind of walking it
back and the reason they're trying to
Pro Protect free speech here is because
they know that the University students
are very Pro Palestine and anti-israel
so they they want to suck up to them a
little bit as
well we also know that they hate
conservative speakers on campus in fact
I'm I'm not going to say which one one
of the people who was at this hearing I
was invited to this school this semester
and then the administration threw up a
ton of roadblocks cuz they don't want me
a completely mainstream conservative an
ordinary American conservative who just
articulates views that were almost
universally held for almost all of
history and especially in our
country they throw up roadblocks to that
but if I go out and say hey from the
land of the sea kill all the Jews then
this well actually look it's context
dependent you know and actually we need
to protect the right to say
that I want to give them as much credit
as I possibly can if
they seriously have bought their own
rhetoric on Free Speech if they
seriously believe that a university an
educational institution is not entitled
to have standards and norms and to
distinguish between truth and falsehood
and good and bad then they have no
business running a university and two
they violated one of the biggest rules
one of the most important things you
ever teach child which is never believe
your own press releases the Liberals in
the 60s who ran the free speech moov
movement they didn't really believe that
they just wanted to destroy conservative
norms and standards and and articulate
their their subversive ideas but the
moment that they were able to do that
and crack up the old conservative
standards what did they do they
immediately reinstituted all the speech
codes on their terms to exclude us from
the Public Square and to enshrine their
views as sacran and holy
now the rest of the show continues now
Professor Jacob has promised me my
concussed associate producer who's on
the road with me and is right there just
right off camera he has promised me that
we will have an iPad for today's show
even though we are on the road and if he
does not he's getting another concussion
no that's not he's he's a beefy guy I
wouldn't want to throw a punch at
Professor Jacob uh you can chat with me
and maybe even with him in the member
block if you're not a member of
theom segmentum then you got to go over
dailywire.com use code nlls get two
months free on all annual
plans
[Music]
a